let's play a game shall we the sorceress
is one of the most bloody successful
horror franchises of all time and
jigsaws work is still far from game over
so legacy will splatter 2017 with some
all-new trap happy death-dealing so to
prepare for the gruesomeness still to
come
here's a look at the untold truth of saw
and how it became such a beloved
gorefest
in the first place keep watching or
don't make your choice cheap tricks like
a lot of budding autos Leigh Whannell
and James Wan had almost no money to
make their first movie together so they
had to think cheap when coming up with
the bare bones of their fright flick and
what's more budget-friendly than in its
higher movie about two guys stuck in a
single room together at first they
thought of having their characters stuck
in an elevator with the whole movie made
up of the security footage a concept
which might have prevented M night
Shyamalan devil from ever happening
but who knows one even conceived of a
paranormal activity like home footage
concept before that series came to be
but ultimately they settled on the dank
bathroom setting that would become so
iconic to the series first blood to
court investors one L and one made a
short film on a shoestring budget that
showcased the joys originality and
money-saving savvy in it one L starred
as the character who has to rifle around
in a living friend's intestines to find
the key to the reverse bear trap on his
head and that role would eventually be
played in the full film by actress
Shaunie Smith whom James Wan had a major
crush on since he was a kid the spec
also featured a billy puppet made by one
himself using ping-pong balls paper
towel tubes and paper mache and the
design was so creeptastic that they
didn't bother changing it for the full
film head case the idea for John jigsaw
Kramer the mastermind behind most of the
series sinister games stemmed from a
surprising
one else own cranial treatment the
rudder had been experiencing migraines
and when he went through some testing he
imagined what it would be like to get
the bad news of his own impending
expiration day and how someone might
react you might not have had a medical
issue but his mind was definitely
twisted show me the money
after saw proved to be a surprise
runaway hit at the box office grossing a
hundred and three million worldwide
against a reported 1.2 million dollar
budget actor Cary Elwes was pretty
displeased with the comparatively small
slice of the pie he received from the
proceeds in a suit filed against the
production companies and produces Ellis
alleged that he was only paid about
$55,000 in all even though he was
promised at least 1% of the producer
profits he sought half a million in
damages and the parties eventually
settled out of court
the acrimony must not have lasted long
because Elvis came back to the franchise
to reprise he's dr. Gordon roll a few
films later congratulations dr. Gordon
you serve are desperate for the sequel
given the massive success of the first
movie Lionsgate was in a rush to get saw
to moving right away and the producers
thought outside of the bathroom box for
the second installment up-and-comer
Darren Lynn Bausman
had already written a screenplay for his
own film called the desperate but it was
criticized for being too similar to saw
so producers saw an opportunity to
tinker with basements flick and
transform it into a follow-up for their
own his foray into the saw series was so
successful that he remained on board as
a director of the third and fourth films
as well sticking point although nearly
all of the traps in the saw series were
complicated none could be more
labor-intensive than the needle pit
scene from sore to 120,000 needles were
needed to fill the prickly VAT and it
took around-the-clock team four
days to replace the real needles with
fiber-optic tips for Shawnee Smith's
safety after all that prep making the
site poke free a crew member
accidentally knocked a pile of real
needles back into the heap so they had
to hold production before it could even
begin to locate them
director basement later joked on reddit
that it was like finding a needle in a
needle stack good one good blood as a
nod to all the on-screen bloodshed in
the first two sore films saw three
theatrical promotion included a poster
made using a real vial of actor Tobin
Bell's blood mixed with reading to
create the most visually jarring shade
for his cloak in the image Lionsgate
printed 1000 copies of the design and
auctioned it off to benefit the Red
Cross in addition to hosting a series of
blood drives organized by the studio
that raised thousands of pints for the
organization toilet humor there's very
little levity to being seen on screen in
the saw series but behind the scenes the
cast and crew found ways to keep the
mood light one running gag during the
production was the use of a hidden fart
machine that was set up during
particularly difficult scenes just a
mess with the actors
that's not all during Belles nude morgue
seen his splayed out exposure got him
cupped in the nether regions by co-stars
talk about your crew Schumer friendly
favors rather than rebuild to the
bathroom set from the first film foresaw
three the filmmakers simply called in a
favor to the makers of scary movie 4 and
used their replica - the basketball hoop
and fallen pipe course
oopsy-daisy in 2010 one Massachusetts
theater full of children was supposed to
show an innocent screening of the
animated flick Megamind but that wasn't
the film that actually started to roll
instead it was saw 3d
some of the children supposedly
experienced nightmares after seeing the
first few minutes which is
understandable considering the opening
scene has two men who have to hacksaw
their shared girlfriend to save
themselves sleep tight kids thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which source story you
liked most